I recently developed, I recently developed a caper store of the soft palette for the first time in my life.
It did seem to correlate with stress, but since then I have to avoid coffee,
acidic fruits, or it becomes irritated again. For this, be indicating a deeper physiological issue,
or put it be just diet related. So what are caper stores, cold sores? What are they? They are
herpes virus. Some viruses are just nearly impossible to get rid of. They harbor in our cells,
they harbor in our bodies, the oral herpes, viruses, harbor in the nerve ganglia, the trigeminal ganglion
on both sides, and they live there until there's an opportunity. And usually the opportunity is
when we get a change of pH in our mouth. So when our both drastically changes pH,
that gives an opportunity for that virus to come down. What does that?
When you suck out a limit, I mean that's a drastic acidic change in pH. When you go under
go stress, that's a change that changes your pH. So there's lots of different things that change
your pH. Some people will say, I get my cold sores when this happens. It's just, you know,
all the time I can tell it, it goes around this time of the month or this time of the year,
or when I do this, or when I consume this, and I regret it afterwards. So how can you get rid
of them? L-I-Z is a amino acid that has been proven to help with cold sores.
Taking a calcium lactate tablet, you can get calcium lactate, it's not any store, and sucking on that
has helped with some people. Wedding a calcium lactate tablet and dabbing it on the cold
sores has helped some people. And then just being aware to try to balance that pH of your
mouth where you're not eating acidic foods or something that you know this is irritating that.
How do you kill the virus so that it doesn't happen again? Well, sometimes you just can't.
I wish I could say, oh, well, you just have to do this, take these supplements or use the right
machine that will knock it out every time. There isn't just, there's no proven way that you're
going to always kill this virus. If you do have a right machine, use the right
on the herbicide. That has been helpful for a lot of people too. If you don't have a right,
try those other nutritional things and dietary things. It's a tough thing. But once you have that
virus, they tend to stay around a long time. They tend to be difficult to get rid of, and you just have
to keep them at bay.